Film Courage: And so, what’s your connect
to the film tonight?
You are in this movie [THE EAST].
What made you say “yes” to the role?
Actress Danielle Macdonald: It’s an amazing
script and I would never turn it down.
It was amazing.
The experience was even better than the script.
It was just one of those things that made
it an incredible experience with such a great
group with such amazing actors.
Film Courage: [Referring to the theme of the
film THE EAST regarding anarchist groups known
for executing attacks on major corporations]
In terms of anarchy, how far would you go
for a role such as what would you do to obtain
information, or get yourself seen in front
of a casting director?
What type of extreme measures would you take?
Danielle Macdonald: [Laughs] I mean…I’m
not very extreme.
I’m a little more on the flip side.
I want to go in there and do the best that
I can do and if that’s right, that’s right.